اسامه لنعود مره اخرى الى قطاع غزه ونشاهد
هذه الصور المباشر لما قلنا قبل قليل بان
الجيش الاسرائيلي اعلن بانه ينفذ في هذه
اللحظات عمليات قصف لمواصفها باهداف في
قطاع غزه وهذه الصور مباشره نشاهد اذا
نشاهد اذا يبدو انه قصف شديد في
هذا الهدف في قطاع غزه
اخر اذن
تقريبا في نفس المنطقه
من زاويه متابعه الكاميرا في هذه اللحظه
في قطاع غزه طبعا سوف نحاول الاستضاح
الاماكن مع مراسلي الجزيره من قطاع غزه
لهذه العمليه التي يقوم بها الجيش
الاسرائيلي في قطاع غزه كما قال طبعا
تبعنا في الساعات الماضيه توصيات من قبل
الجيش الاسرائيلي للحكومه الاسرائيليه بان
يكون ردها قويا في قطاع غزه عقب العام
التي قامت بها فصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
في غلاف غزه ونشاهد هذه الصور المباشره
لهذا القصف الشديد لهذه الاهداف في قطاع
غزه في هذه اللحظات التي يقوم فيها الجيش
الاسرائيلي كما قال بما وصفها باهداف
في قطاع غزه سوف نسعى الى استبيان طبيعه
هذه الاهداف في هذه الساعات
وفي هذه الصور المباشره من قطاع غزه نذكر
بالسياق السياسي وربما الذي من خلاله قد
نفهم هذه التطورات وما حدث عقب استشهاد
الشيخ خضر عدنان عقب ايام طويله من اعلانه
لاعلان للعذراء بنعاني الطعام نتيجه
اعتقاله استشهد الشيخ خضر عدنان
وبعد ذلك شاهدنا الاحتجاجات في الشارع
الفلسطيني مواقف من قبل
الاطياف وفصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه خاصه
من حركه الجهاد التي ينتمي لها الشيخ
عدنان خضر شاهدنا عمليات من قبل فصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه ثم جاءت توصيات من
قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي للحكومه الاسرائيليه
بان يكون الرد قويا على هذه الرقشه
الرشقات في غلاف غ زه وفي هذه اللحظات
نتابع هذه الصور المباشره